Israel's military offensive in Gaza
continues and the devastation is only
increasing you might be wondering what
exactly is Israel trying to achieve in
Gaza an analysis of Israeli Army's
tweets shows the reasons have been
changing here's how first it was all
about the three Israeli teens who were
kidnapped and killed in June
Netanyahu immediately blamed Hamas
without so much as a shred of evidence
Hamas terrorists carried out Thursday's
kidnapping of three Israeli teenagers
that narrative was everywhere
there any doubts for you at this point
that Hamas is responsible no there's no
doubt the three teens who were brutally
murdered by the Hamas terrorists
unfortunately there's no doubt about
that but guess what it's now been
confirmed by Israeli officials that the
kidnappings were carried out by a lone
cell not operating under Hamas
leadership they later tried to take back
that statement regardless right after
the kidnappings Israel heavily cracked
down in the occupied West Bank with
raids and arrests and Hamas responded by
firing rockets into Israel from Gaza all
of that led to this current offensive
operation protective edge israel's
narrative then shifted to the rocket
attacks here's what we heard no country
on earth will remain passive in the face
of hundreds of rockets fired on its
cities but Israel is no exception we
come up compromise with death we cannot
compromise with rockets the objective of
this mission is very simple we need to
restore deterrence we need to end the
rocket fire Israel says more than 2,800
Rockets have been fired from Gaza since
July 8 resulting in three civilian
deaths 90% of the rockets targeted by
the Iron Dome
and interceptive protecting Israeli
lives
still Israel justifies its military
offensive in Gaza saying it has a right
to defend itself but if this is about
defense
why do Gaza civilians make up more than
75% of the Dead according to the UN and
why of hospitals homes schools and
markets being directly targeted by
Israel in violation of international law
so after the kidnappings and then the
rocket attacks Israel now says the
operation is about the tunnels there's a
maze of teratomas in Gaza that is geared
to penetrate our territory coming into
itself to try to kill our people Israel
launched a ground invasion into Gaza on
July 17th to destroy what it says is a
sophisticated network of tunnels used by
Hamas and other groups Palestinians say
they've primarily used the tunnels to
smuggle in food and supplies barred from
entering the strip israel has known
about them for years but now israel says
it won't end its offensive until all the
tunnels are destroyed at Kuni kallu a
SWAT monocular Mahoney who Simlish limas
Amazo him Oh bleep cicadas the changing
tune only suggests Israel provoked a war
in Gaza without clear objectives
assuming all the rockets are stopped and
the tunnels are blown up the question
remains what is Israel's endgame in Gaza
and given that Israel won't end its
siege of the strip's is this just about
maintaining the status quo the world is
left wondering especially the people in
Gaza what do you think the next chapter
will be let us know in the comments
below
[Music]